[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in Wolfenstein alternate 1980s Nazis
remain a force of evil across Europe
thus the Nazi killing continues as a
blaskowitz twins Justin so pick up where
their parents left off for this spinoff
Wolfenstein Youngblood it's a relentless
co-op RPG light shooter driven by an
unapologetic youthful attitude it may
not reach the same heights of its
predecessors but Youngblood hits where
it counts Justin self and their best
friend Abbi immediately come to life
with a striking contrast from their
parents their boisterous and sometimes
dorky the same way many teenagers and
young adults are it gives them genuine
personalities that mostly come off cool
as hell especially with stellar voice
acting and silly moments like elevator
loading screens with a decent pop tunes
[Music]
with BJ gone missing they uncover clues
to his disappearance and take matters
into their own hands
there were out Nazi occupied France to
find their dad and well kill Nazis as
either Jess or Soph
with their co-op or AI partner as the
other sister you join a French
resistance movement in new Paris which
quickly boils down to you raiding Nazi
outposts and strongholds with them slick
dot you shoot suits with the twins
inseparable
co-op is at the heart of the experience
and thankfully partnering up online is a
breeze you can have friends or randoms
jump into your session seamlessly
without interruption the AI will assume
control until a player connects and
again right as a player leaves and when
players have identical missions in their
quest log completing it records progress
for both players
and if you rather go it alone alongside
a decent AI companion it's just as
viable for the entire game
sláinte gameplay-wise
Youngblood captures that familiar
Wolfenstein feeling of taking an
automatic shotgun to a Nazi soldier
melting an armor clad super soldier with
a laser rifle or zapping a horde with a
lightning coil and what a powerful
feeling it is what's new is a number of
RPG light twists tougher enemies have
one of two armor elements that are weak
to corresponding weapons encouraging you
to actively juggle your varied arsenal a
slightly more diverse weapon upgrade
system helps flesh out some familiar
firearms there's also a character
progression system where you rack up XP
to level up then dump upgrade points
into new skills and perks
these are simple systems that help
facilitate steady unlocks making you
feel like you're getting ever more
devastating but never overpowered solid
gunplay and some neat mechanics wouldn't
mean much without the proper combat
encounters to complement them and
Youngblood delivers you'll often pull
out all the stops to either finish
combat scenarios or realize that you
have to retreat to rethink your approach
stealth alone isn't really an option but
it's a good way to thin out the
opposition before going all-out guns
blazing it can get overwhelming when
super soldiers massive mechs and a bomb
strapped panzer who and bear down on you
but that's when Youngblood is at its
best intense firefights can break out
anywhere with little warning and the
main missions manage to keep a
consistent action-packed momentum
throughout
Youngblood leans more into an open
structure about making new Paris a group
of separate districts where you find
your missions the main questline
branches from the hub areas but out on
the streets side missions and random
events fill in the spaces listen up
sisters there's a high-value target
using a car parked near your location
get there and plant a bomb on it
good luck sisters there conducive for
racking up early XP getting familiar
with district layouts and soaking up the
vibe of a downtrodden 1980s pears but
quickly feel like filler that bulk out
your to-do list levels do have a hint of
Arkane Studios influence sometimes
reminding me of dishonored it spices up
combat with some verticality and allows
light exploration for alternate routes
or collectables it's a successful
incorporation of that studio strengths
and the game is better for it
now the Paris catacombs act as your safe
hub in Youngblood it's not as extensive
as the new Colossus is u-boat home and
you won't get much from the inhabitants
as there are nowhere near as involved as
Wolfenstein 2 supporting cast they're
more just quest givers
however just tsofen abbey are there to
pick up the slack i decrypted fragments
of stolen Nazi Intel on the computer
witness reports from Nazis who survived
the encounter with Captain blaskowitz
piecing together the fragmented
information I deduced that he was
looking for a place called lab X where
he must be been the story overall
doesn't reach the same highs as the new
Colossus
it's an incredibly tough act to follow
really but aside from a cheap plot twist
and underwhelming villains most of young
bloods lean story is a fun ride to that
end the game is less about a bold
fleshed out narrative and more about
instilling an infectious charisma in its
star characters to match the
over-the-top action and it sews the
seats for what's next in Wolfenstein
leaving the door wide open for some
exciting wild possibilities there are
traces of an ongoing game here you can
take on daily and weekly challenges as
they cycle into the game or replay story
missions on harder difficulties for
increasing amounts of XP and currency
which is a bit more enticing while it's
a bog-standard way to keep the co-op
experience going they at least offer an
outlet to try new tactics as these
harder modes can be quite unforgiving
the end game may not be extensive but
the ride was exciting enough that the
content feels like a little value-added
mr. Wolfenstein Youngblood has a series
signature first person shooting thrills
that will have you gladly busting shots
and blasting lasers in the face of Nazi
trash and the opportunity to do so
alongside a friend the fight carries on
to the next generation and the way the
spin-off bronze the saga with the
blaskowitz twins makes you wish there
was more to see from this new cast of
lovable knuckleheads Jess and self and
Abby to learn from the best and they
embrace their newfound duty of ridding
the world of tyranny while being cool as
hell doing it Youngblood is short but oh
so sweet stewardesses just like daddy
told us
[Music]